[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es erfolgt nun die meldung durch die
kommandanten der ausgerückten truppe an
den stellvertretenden regale kommen
jägerbrigade während ober ganz langsam
gleich darauf folgt die bundes filme um
den anschluss daran scheiterte der
stellvertretende kommandant gemeinsam
mit kermani paar jungs konnten
der melker pioniere herrn oberstleutnant
michael frauen unmittelbar daran erfolgt
die große parade
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
einerlei
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich darf nur das war eine komponenten
und amerika pioniere der oberstleutnant
michael fuchs übergeben
im anschluss folgt ein
[Musik]
sehen sie diesen tag als festakt werden
sie auch in zukunft gerne aktiv
[Musik]
teilzunehmen
ich darf nun als unsere ehrengäste
herzlich willkommen heißen
der gesamt groß gilt unserem steht
vertreten bringen
hannovers brands gesagt als willkommen
bei der mega wird ein herzliches den
vertretern des kerns herr overath
man gießt der oliver otto und herren
geht ihr senior magister welche
lettinger herzlich willkommen
ich freue mich ganz besonders
symbolisch als vertreter für angehörige
und freunde
ulrike und christian vielhaber die
eltern eines gruppen willkommen zu
lassen eine besondere freude ist es das
aber darf xi und zu versuchen ihre
kappen des entwicklungs termines in 20
ich freue mich sehr dass sie sich der
ableistung des grundwehrdienstes
entschieden haben und nur soldaten des
bfp der maker in ihrer sind webinare
sind mädchen als spezialisten als helfer
in der not bekam ihre kommandanten und
ausbilder verfügen wir das sehr lange
erfahrung im bereich der ausbildung
sie werden während ihrer zeit sehr viele
verschiedenartige ausbildungen über sich
ergehen lassen
manche von ihnen mit einen oder anderen
satz voll stolz hier zu sehen
das leben können
[Musik]
haben wir einen stimmigen rahmen als
mehr sein dazu gebunden
der zweite vatikanische konzil diese
große versammlung der katholischen
bischöfe in den 1960 er jahren hat
wissen wir halten
wer als soldat im inselstaat landes
steht mit achte sich als leader der
freiheit das geld kürzen
als garant und sicherer es ist die
ureigenste aufgabe als sonntag waren in
dieser dimension mit allen mitteln zu
verteidigen
liberec ich wünsche euch für eure zeit
im österreichischen bundesheer so
verwinkelt sollte sind erfüllt
die ausbildung dazu den geist der
kameradschaft in einer neuen dimension
über soziale grenzen hinweg die wir
draußen gehen sondern gesellschaft
aufgebaut haben seid euch immer wieder
bewusst
30 soldaten steht nicht die waffe
verhandelten gewinnt etwas wasser
täglich irgendjemanden der hat die
oberfläche
[Musik]
das gewissermaßen als motto für den
grundwehrdienst möchte ich euch ans herz
legen und möchte euch in einem gebet für
euch auf einen dienst und deswegen
großes bieten
herr unser gott wir bitten dich um
deinen segen für diese jungen kameraden
war es ihnen
in filmen und allen anderen üben lassen
die kameradschaft und das geht nur mit
euch gar nicht
[Musik]
es wird nur herr oberst franz langthaler
seine worte nicht danach fragen
[Musik]
allerdings für euer land oberösterreich
im österreichischen position zu leisten
und dafür haben möchte ich meinen
respekt und meine anerkennung
aussprechen damit das bundesheer
wirksamen schutz in familienfreundliche
freund das treuegelöbnis zur republik
westerkappeln ein gelöbnis mit einem
neuen kräften und die notfall auch mit
der waffe und für die sicherheit unserer
bevölkerung zu stehen
das bedürfnis nach sicherheit ist ein
grundbedürfnis jeden menschen
sicherheit ist die elementare
voraussetzung dass die mannschaft die in
der familie reicht bis zum strahlung
oder sogar über nationale
zusammenschlüssen wie zum beispiel die
europäische union
wir als bürger der republik österreich
haben das privileg in einem umfeld
aufgewachsen zu sein das vom
militärischen krisen in den letzten
jahren und jahrzehnten verschont
geblieben ist
wobei es nicht angebracht ist sich
deswegen zurückzulehnen und vitale
sicherheitsvorsorge zu vernachlässigen
krisen kommen meistens überraschen und
ohne vorwarnung und werde nicht gerüstet
war
diese ist enthält diese krisen vorsorgen
und ein unverzichtbarer bestandteil der
hebräischen umfassenden
landesverteidigung
dies hat gerade bei der aktuellen carola
pandemie ganz eklatant erleben können
oder sogar müssen
seit märz des vergangenen jahres haben
tausende soldaten die gesundheits- und
sicherheitsbehörden schon zu lassen
gegen die unkontrollierte ausbreitung
dieser neuartigen auch im späteren leben
gut anstehen einen wichtigen beitrag zur
sicherstellung der einsatzbereitschaft
des kommissions- geschützte kunden
beziehen sie ergründet ins revier dienst
an der allgemeinheit hoch als einen ganz
frühen schritt zum erwachsenwerden und
zur persönlichen reifung pflegen sie den
kontakt mit ihnen verraten
am leben sind die sprichwörtliche
militärische kameradschaft nehmen das
verstärkte körperliche training um das
hinter nächsten monaten erfahren werden
mit hinaus in das zivile leben und
erhalten sie ihre gesteigerte fitness
als lebenslange gesundheitsvorsorge
diesem anlass möchte ich aber auch
den verantwortlichen kommandanten und
ausrichtern des pd bataillons danke für
ihre geleistete arbeit sagen
gleichzeitig möchte ich sie auf weiter
und auch weiterhin ihren soldaten
vorgesetzten kommandanten sondern auch
coaches und berater und begleiter zu
sein und mit viel fingerspitzengefühl
ihre verantwortungsvolle funktion
ausüben
abschließend dass ich heute gesetzte
rekruten einen erfolgreichen
unfallfreien aber auch erlebnisreisen
von aufbau des wehrdienstes bilden
finanzierte kontakte im kreis und vor
allem viel zeit partenkirchen
es lebe das als deutscher kommissar es
neben jungs schöne heimat republik
verteilt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
er folgt das beste des 21
[Musik]
die republik
gehorsam
[Musik]